[Musik]
dort unten dort will ich mich
niederlassen wildpoldsried denn hier
produzieren sie ihren eigenen strom das
ist geil und modern so wie ich
hallo ich komme aus der großstadt wo
gibt es denn hier die beste avocado ball
statt sich nur zu euch jetzt hat mir
sympathisch ist jetzt wichtig dass man
auch tag ist gerade in der situation was
mache ich jetzt wie kann ich zu euch wo
kann ich hin haben sie den ort für mich
haben sie im bett frei haben sie ein
haus haben sie irgendwas
was jetzt ein bissel wichtig ist dass
derjenige wurde herr zieht
unsere gepflogenheiten respektiert was
werden
das muss jeder selber
ich fühle mich hier sauwohl
aber manche sind hier um elf noch
nüchtern zum beispiel die
bürgermeisterin und der stellvertretende
hallo
das ist ja hier
selbstversorger dorf kann man sagen kann
was sagen was was heißt das konkret das
heißt dass wir deutlich mehr
regenerativen strom erzeugen als wir
brauchen kann man sagen wie viel mehr
ist achtmal mehr achtmal mehr strom aus
100 prozent tatsächlich
[Musik]
du hast mir nicht hier am energie campus
werden wind solar und biogas vernetzt
hier ist immer strom für immer das heißt
wenn mal keine sonne scheint kein wind
weht dann haben eben über 100 prozent
strom das ist jetzt hier diedorf heizung
und hier wird das ganze dorf wird
geheizt kann man sagen die großen fragen
der großen dorf des zentrums sorgen dort
ja groß sein also 80 hausanschlüsse
hausanschlüsse sehr viel
die hälfte verstanden die untertitel das
da gibt es zum beispiel oktober leitet
als beispiel plus setzen etc
kuhglocken
kuhglocken ja soll ich leuten nein die
kohl und darin sich leute auf nach soja
die müssen natürlich weg nein doch also
keine leute ganz im ernst wenn ich
morgen aufwache als work life balance
ist so wichtig wenn es klingelt
richtzeit der bank das ist jetzt eine
biogasanlage wie funktioniert die ja
also hier produzieren wir mit biomasse
aus der region strom und wärme für die
region und was ist das genau gülle das
ist die kacke war will ja nicht raus
[Musik]
40 jahre
trecker fahren um scheiße abzuholen muss
ich auch nicht unbedingt haben von wegen
saubere energie
okay wir waren jetzt beim nachbar wir
haben dann die küche holt die kommt
jetzt bei rhein in die grube rey und aus
der gülle machen die bakterien dann
strom und wärme alles klar das heißt ich
muss nur das denn nochmal hören möchte
kann auch ganz schnell auch ganz schnell
hoch
das kann man vollkommen in der
landwirtschaft
macht eure scheiße allein
das ist natur pur
ich haste scheiße am fuß haste scheiße
ich habe beschlossen hier kann ich nicht
bleiben für so ein bisschen strom ist
mir das echt so anstrengend und habe mir
abend mit
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
märz gut
los
los du scheiße fährt